salut les terriens scène intérieure je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver
notre invité principal ce soir c'est
karl lagarfeld
karl lagarfeld bonsoir alors vous n'avez
plus votre éventail vous vous êtes
habitué à l'odeur de la france
zach thomas et puis je veux dire une
chose les gens fument moins on est plus
exposé à tous alors en revanche vous
avez toujours vos lunettes de soleil il
fait si beau que ça autour de vous car
non mais vous avez les mets tout seul et
que c'est une chose de politesse dans
les verres teintés embellissent tout le
monde donc je reconnaîtrais allait
retirer puisque tout le monde prend dix
ans a profité des gardes puisque le
monde est plus jolie ainsi alors j'ai
l'impression de vos cheveux n'ont jamais
été aussi blanc car vous les faites
bouillir ou quoi non pas du tout pas du
tout mes cheveux sont de plus en plus
blancs parce que je met de plus en plus
de shampoing secte et klorane je
m'excuse de la publicité mais qui me
pose la question je réponds alors là
bien sûr je m'adresse à la marionnette
parce que carl vous dit qu'on jouait à
la télé en fait c'est ma marionnette qui
va c'est ce que les gens vont attendre
de moi c'est ça oui oui et puis j'ai
parle souvent à d'autres marionnettes
voilà alors qu'arles vous connaissez les
missions on perd nous serons tous les
deux nous parlerons de vous nous
parlerons de votre carrière de vos
succès de votre triomphe jusqu'au cola
light karl lagerfeld qui permet de faire
des ro karl lagerfeld
les normes grâce à ça on appelle les
roches ignées
l'émission s'appelle cette [ __ ]
en levant tél
[Musique]
alors qu'arles vous êtes partout alors
autour naître ici très heureux de vous
avoir ce soir vous sortez de l'elysée où
nicolas sarkozy vient de vous faire
commandeur de la légion d'honneur
un beagle
[Musique]
ça vous oublie pas d'être décoré légion
d'honneur comme didier barbelivien et
daniela lumbroso qu'un non pas du tout
on m'avait dit toute façon on ne pouvait
pas refuser et je me vois pas dire
nicolas c'est un coup dur que tu
monsieur très gentil mais donc la mode
le garder
mais ça aurait été une insulte à la
france absolument alors l'elysée dont
chanel bien sûr alors ils sont tellement
classe vos définitionnelle que
maintenant c'est pas les mannequins qui
défilent devant le public mais le public
qui défilent devant les mannequins
de la nouveauté il ya aussi le catalogue
des 3 suisses dont vous avez fait la
conception et les photos mais pas les
modèles c est amusant mais à les 3
suisses avec la crise sont plus que deux
c'est vrai
le cola on en a parlé vous avez dessiné
une collection de lunettes pour optic
2000 oui oui bah que vous savez c'est
une chose presque logique étant donné
que j'emporte tout le temps moi je
trouve que c'est très bien de d'avoir
beaucoup de contacts faire beaucoup de
choses et même pas pour gagner de
l'argent c'est parce qu'il faut rester
dans une mouvance d'aujourd'hui si on
fait le métier que je fais alors qu'est
ce que vous faites d'autres karl des
brosses à dents des non non mais c'est
pas contre parce que les gens qui put la
bouche c'est pas très bon
alors vous dites je ne travaille pas
j'ai pas besoin de réfléchir c'est un
flash électronique et ça me prend plus
de temps de le mettre sur le banc greek
de l'avant l'idée finalement dit oui
mais ça ne marche pas toujours et pas de
garantie mais j'ai la chance d'en voler
vision très définitive peu avant le
réveil aussi pour les décors de défiler
et tout mais ça c'est une chance mais je
fais pas compter dessus votre pire idée
c'est quoi la plus mauvaise idée que j
ai jamais eu assez de savoir faire pour
tourner ça dans une bonne idée
alors en revanche vous n'avez aucune
complaisance envers vous même vous dites
je suis auto fasciste car pour survivre
il ne faut rien se passer c'est aux
fêtes mots un peu durs pour une
discipline qui au fait à la fin ne me
coûte rien je me suis habitué à ça je
suis comme les animaux qu'ils mangent
que les plantes qui sont bons pour eux
qui touchent pas mais c'est aussi simple
que ça c'est une chose d'instinct c'est
très étrange alors vous êtes une star
mondiale un quart des dd penthouse de
new york aux hlm de banlieue quand vous
habitiez rue de l'université il y avait
des gens qui faisait vos poubelles oui
mais la rue limete maintenant c'est un
palais africains c'est moi l'arrêt
aujourd'hui vous êtes quai voltaire et
quand vous mettez devant votre fenêtre
les japonais vouent prennent en photo
des japonais depuis les bateaux mouches
oui on peut pas oui puis il annonce mon
nom est distinct la habite monsieur
madame chirac et karl lagerfeld je vais
déménager à cause de ça mais en même
temps c'est flatteur quelquefois je veux
dire mais vous savez je suis pas
victoria beckham
alors cette image cette marionnette
comme vous dites c'est votre armure vous
êtes très bavard mais en fait on sait
rien de vous vous dites la vérité je ne
veux pas la dire donc je suis obligé de
me taire je n'ai pas grand chose à dire
je n'ai pas à analyser les états d'âme
en public se trouve ça un public never
explain never complain exact exact vous
dites on doit s'occuper de soi même en
fait ah oui parce que les laisser aller
ses papillons c'est mignon à 20-30 ans
après occuper un peu tout ça alors vous
vivez seul et vous dites quand elle
résulte d'un choix la solitude et le
comble du luxe est vrai qu est tout à
fait parce que d'être pauvres malades
abandonnés et tout ça ça doit être le
comble de l'horreur ouais mais si vous
luttez pour avoir la paix ça les courbes
horrible mais malheureusement c'est
comme ça c'est heureux j'ai vu lire que
la même chose en même temps et dieu sait
que je travaille beaucoup pour le métier
que j'aime le plus c'est à dire la mode
la photo est l'édition mais j'ai besoin
aussi de temps tout lire pour tous c'est
pas pour y faire étalage de sa chaussure
tout se sait jamais les discours
intellectuel je vois les discussions
intellectuelles je n'aime que le
superficiel
mais sanaa blij pas être con à
l'intérieur
alors car
question sexe ses solos également vous
dites j'aime seulement les escortes haut
de gamme je n'aime pas couché avec les
gens que j'aime vraiment ça serait assez
la vérité dans l'absolu mais je vous dis
pas que la réalité c'est conforme à ses
phrases qui est plutôt une constatation
donc je ne suis pas obligé donner des
détails et des explications oui alors
pas beaucoup de sexe vous savez j'ai
commencé jeune oui vous en avez fait
beaucoup j'ai donné
la drogue j'ai vu beaucoup de monde en
prendre et ça leur a pas réussi je
préfère voir l'effet des drogues sur les
autres que sur moi j'admire les gens qui
ont dont d'autodestruction et je devrais
pas le dire mais je ne sais pas qui a
dit dès plus facile de savoir comment
c'est détruire que comment se sauver
mais moi malheureusement je suis pas
doué pour me perdre j'ai fait pour se
vivre
et donc vous prenez pas de drogue non
j'ai pas besoin je suis déjà grisé tout
seul alors les habiller comme sage
sans drogue
alors pas de vacances non plus pas de
vacances non j'ai fais un métier qui est
tellement soumis à des calendriers
bizarre que le mot vacances ne rentre
pas et puis pour la profession libérale
congé n'est pas payé
alors pas de restaurant gastronomique
non plus il ya longtemps que vous avez
compris que dans votre vie intérieure le
plus important c'était de rentrer dans
les 34 finalement
c'est pas de 34 ans et pas une ride
d'hommes mais je ne fais jamais les
vêtements essayé il faut tout leur
entrée dans les vêtements c'est pas les
vêtements qui doit mal et c'est moi qui
dois aller aux vêtements c'est comme une
discipline je ne pensais pas un vêtement
d'une taille ou du sud et 48 jeunes et
possède pas alors vous avez une vie
monacale une vie monacale de luxe est
vraiment à calais faut être croyant je
suis très croyant et est ce que vous
êtes riches parce que vous êtes très
très riche vous savez les échelles de
richesse sont tellement d'efforts mais
aujourd'hui que c'est presque une
coquetterie de dire qu'on est pauvre par
rapport à bill gates par exemple goût de
l'art de la tête vous très pauvre dallas
n'ont voulu et ça c'est disproportionné
mais ceci dit il fait un très bon usage
son argent monsieur oui c'est donc il ya
toute mon admiration alors il ya un truc
que je comprends pas il paraît que vous
avez 200 i-pod vous savez pas qu'on peut
mettre plusieurs chansons sur un ippon
non non non ça j'ai déjà appris mais
vous savez mais ipod ont des références
derrière et c'est ce qu'a dessus et il
ya à peu près une dizaine ou une
vingtaine de deux dvd car je les achète
je fais mes choix et tout dessus sinon
ça m'embête arif recherché c'est trop
long j'ai pas de temps alors en fait
vous êtes vous êtes débarrassé de
beaucoup de choses vite je déteste
posséder c'est vrai qu'à un moment de
votre vie vous êtes débarrassé de
plaintes
mieux qu'on puisse faire c'est il ya un
proverbe allemand qui dit
ni maps et une crise dites adieu il
récupérer votre santé ouais ça mais il
faut que j'en parle j'adore faire des
collections parc de consoles vendues
collection des choses mais après j'ai
pas envie de le posséder la seule chose
dont je me sépare pas c'est les livres
mais ça 300000 vous à varèse tragique
savez je suis trilingue donc ça élargit
aussi l'éventail
alors vous dites ma vie est irréel dans
la mesure où j'ai tout fait pour
échapper à la réalité de la vie je me
suis fait ma réalité qui est en réalité
pour d'autres mais sa fonction pour le
genre de métier que je fais il pour les
gens de vie que je veux mais née il ya
presque pas de réalité dans votre
existence finalement il ya des réalités
on veut attraper un rhume c'est pas
c'est passé ma vie à vouloir éviter une
confrontation déplaisante avec une
réalité qui préfèrent ignorer c'est un
luxe vous regardez pas la télé vous
écoutez pas la radio vous n'aimez pas
les les voix étrangères qui envahissent
votre univers oui parce que tout est
dans ma tête et dans mon imagination je
n'aime pas le préfabriqué par d'autres
pour moi j'ai ma vision et je préfère
rester avait avec ça j'ai pas assez de
temps non plus parce que je dessine où
j'écris parce que je fais des facs
encore où j'écris des lettres parce que
ce téléphone peut je te dis jamais les
portables n'est rien parce qu'on dérange
les gens ne sait pas où on tombe moi je
fais porter mes lettres
vous parlez toujours aussi vite en fait
c'est parce que votre mère vous disais
chaque jour tu as quatre minutes pour me
dire ce que tu as à me dire et alors
c'est toujours l'accent 1 quand même oui
j'ai une façon d'être en jeu par les
mânes allemands aussi on me dit un
accent en anglais aussi je reconnais que
ma voix est étrange mais je peux pas
faire autrement j'ai appris le français
quand il est arrivé en france en allant
aussi de l'avant avant arriver à 6 ans
je parlais anglais allemand français
quand même bon vocabulaire c'est à peine
élargie si vous voulez mais j'ai jamais
eu à à bûcher je pensais que vous aviez
appris le français en regardant la
septième compagnie au cinéma
non non d'ailleurs j'aurais pas compris
non non non non non non non je me
souviens même les premières choses que
j'ai appris en français le premier poème
que j'ai appris en français ça se
commencer sur les adieux de marivent
tueur à la france quand elle était veuve
à 18 ans et qu'elle part en écosse cela
commence un dieu pays cheryl reste
chaude
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus